the Joe Rogan experience you're a very
articulate guy and I'm sure a lot of
these people are not very educated so
the continued exposure to you is
probably confusing to them as well
because you're so good at forming
sentences and speaking in calm and you
know the words flow so smoothly out of
your mouth and you have these wonderful
it's wonderful grasp of the English
language there probably I think this guy
might be smarter than me help let me say
something though don't be fooled you
know we think of Klan people I say we
had you know people in general because
most of our exposure to it is up the
Jerry Springer Show right or Geraldo
where they throw Cheerios time yeah
third grade dropout right on a thing
caricatures yeah and those are the types
that you know that they would bring on
the show for whatever reason and I know
plenty of those types trust me those
stereotypes do we exist but they can go
anywhere from the third grade dropout
all the way to president of the united
states president warren g harding was
sworn into the ku klux klan in the green
room of the White House what year was
that whatever year he was president so
was my host 65 oh well we got 65 1920s
right was he with the tea the tea down
the dome what it was um
President Harry Truman before Harry
Truman became president he was a member
of the Klan for short Roz that's right
Harry Truman who an integrated the army
all right Wow
he joined for a short time he didn't
like it he got out um Supreme Court
justice Hugo black Hilo black was in the
Klan at the time he was appointed to the
Supreme Court he had to leave the Ku
Klux Klan to sit on this on Supreme
Court as a justice Morton more recently
um Senator Robert Byrd from West
Virginia who just died a few years ago
he was a Klansman in the 1940s he will
he was a grand legal illegal means a
recruit
granion state so he was a recruiter for
the state of West Virginia a grand legal
in the 1940s and then yogi later
renounced it and stuff yeah so you know
all kinds of educational backgrounds
particularly a long time ago yeah yeah I
mean it was considered the an honorable
white man Society at the time you know
they didn't allow women in the clan and
they had a women's auxiliaries now they
allow women but women is still a male
chauvinistic organization so women are
making progress even in the clamp oh
yeah but but they cannot hold the
highest offices they can't be a grand
dragon or dragoness when did you start
on this what year was it I started you
know meeting them and all yes or
researching them just when when when did
you start meeting them when G when did
you have this meeting after the first
the first friendly meeting that I had
with with the Klan was in the bar that
was 1983 but um so my first encounter
with the Klansmen was at the year before
and I didn't know he's the Klansmen I
beat him up oh so this but the bar thing
was at e3 yeah I was wondering it if it
was pre or post the Dave Chapelle bit
that's why and what's funny is you know
everybody asked me you know did you see
that yeah the Clayton Bigsby or whatever
yeah yeah you know they think it's
hilarious but I'm gonna tell you
something it's not hilarious okay Dave
Chappelle he's a comic genius he's great
okay and perhaps if I had never done
what I've done I find a lot of humor in
it yeah but I tell you what he's never
been to a Klan rally I have I've been to
plenty of them those things are not
funny they are not funny okay they are a
pressure cooker waiting to go off
and if that thought was not really you
know released it's going to explode
and we saw that in Charlottesville well
you know that he his joke was yeah in
how ridiculous it was absolutely no God
my fault aligned
yeah I'm not following it's black right
exactly I understand we're saying from
your perspective it's not funny yeah
yeah yeah I mean yeah I mean this humor
and everything but but you know we
shouldn't take take racism you know we
need to take it more seriously than we
do
[Applause]